[Music]
basically that means this is me this is
jane
i left england to go and study
chimpanzees not just any animal but the
one
most like us
the dna of humans and chimpanzees
differs by only just over one percent
they use certain plants as medicine
leaves as sponges each individual has
his or her
own personality
[Music]
chimpanzees have the same kind of
emotions as we do
when the old female flo died the older
child
kept going back to the body pulled the
dead hand towards him
as though trying to make her groom him i
saw him climb a tree
he looked down at this nest where he and
his mother
slept together he climbed down curled up
on the ground
and he died of grief people have said
well it's only humans who have some kind
of spirituality but i don't think so
people need to understand that
chimpanzees are
sentient and sapient because these
chimpanzees had given me so much
i knew i had to do something to conserve
their environment
so i went to africa as a scientist i
left the jungle
as an activist
in this master class i'd like to share
with you all of the amazing
things that i discovered about these
closest relatives of ours
i want to talk about what we all can do
together
to right the wrongs you have an
indomitable spirit
you can make change in your own life
every single day to make this a better
world
there is still a window of time nature
can win if we give her a chance
i'm jane goodall and this is my master
[Music]
class
you